[Music]
what the hell were you doing you're 3
hours late dad you don't understand the
car was busted so we had to shred why
your lips red were you eting a snow cone
that's a really good guess what kind of
adults roller blade the police are here
and they're saying that you bought
alcohol for miners thanks Boys in Europe
the drinking age is like 10 they could
have been European what made you think
they were European they had a certain
gen quality I think one of them was
eating pant
shakala guys everyone thinks we're
losers but that's about to
change I know where The Treasure of
Foggy Mountain is from when we were kids
we looking at 100 Mil $100 million it'd
be like I mean I know it's more than
this but at least a million each
significantly more what are we waiting
for the cute guys that came in earlier
honestly nobody cute the ginger look
like a colonial ghost glasses look like
Tim Burton Drew him and in a short one
we probably were the same size bra they
had a treasure map with like an x on it
we going to steal that
map that is a full on Hawk hey buddy
Traverse it
the does it not know it can fly why did
it walk away with an attitude everyone
is after this treasure we deserve that
you deserve it yeah three white guys
whose biggest issue is what growing up
no it's I feel like it's more Nuance
than
that you just hit a woman I apologize
for him I for one would
never oh my God so one woman that's not
in the
grand welcome new friends we can all
agree this is a scary cult and we're
waiting for the other shoe to drop we're
in a docu series and this is episode 2
dude
completely insane night guys why are we
tied
up I'd rather die and live without you
boys
holy
oh guys look dude that's that's the
treasure door open
it I would be sick I would be sick to
forget the money it's not worth
it
[Music]
a